hi guys my name is camera chambers and
I'm Cody Melcher this is Tamra Jessa and
Cody also just saw two as well
annoyingly today we watched boss baby
yeah more like today we slog through
boss face every five seconds we were to
go to goodie we going oh no I just like
I found out loud like what which I mean
shocking who would have thought that a
children's movie builds around corporate
espionage would be boring there was a
few things that I enjoyed I enjoyed the
cast obviously is great but you were
saying that earlier DreamWorks just
brings in a good cast and they have a
thin plot line which I overcompensated
it had the makings of something that
could have been really cute it's like
Pixar was doing it maybe it's a bit this
didn't deliver story wise at all
I would I would agree with Tamra that it
would be a better movie if other people
had made it differently um going off of
that I will give them credit which we
discussed in the car on the animation uh
animations solid like everything looks
good and then on top of that I did like
the inventiveness of like when they
would go into his imagination and asses
like that like they changed the
animation style to kind of make it
really cool and stylistic I liked it it
was kind of in the vein of as like a
Rugrats thing where they see what's
happening is a completely different
thing and you're like what is real what
is fake what is the imagination was
actually happening they're kind of fun
for especially for for kids I think
seeing this would enjoy that okay two
things one I would agree I would agree
if we were clearer on what was real what
was it because like they know he's
wearing a suit
and has a briefcase because they a cop
to that right like so the parents do see
that they when they come out in the car
chase scene like we see that the cart
age is a real a car chase it's just them
like slowly doing stuff but it stuff is
on fire when they come out so I don't
know how what's real and what's not in
that aspect and also it isn't fun for
kids we had children in the theater the
ones in front of us last twice
the whole movie haha I'm with you I
didn't love this bill but I didn't make
me angry like it me oh yeah I'm not I'm
not angry I'm disappointed oh so much
worse there's a few lines that hit but
mostly the jokes really were flat
they were unfunny they were not new I
liked that they were saying that the
forever puppy is going to make you never
want to have kids like will that make
sense to me that's cute I like that
people don't have babies because they're
cute they have babies because they're
procreating looking for the girls right
there well I should what I should say is
everyone doesn't do that what I mean it
goes to the plot of a story that that
like what your copies are out shooting
baby but you can't just make up Facebook
cause why did you get that Cody's
reactions cuz we were way more
entertaining by the edge of movie
we're said a lot oh for sure I'm with
you I'm just trying to like pull out
some good finger it's something to say
that I mean like Pixar's amazing
Disney's great I really enjoyed the
Smurfs movie that we saw this was an
animation film that just didn't hit many
marks at all like none yeah Lisa Kudrow
was in it so except as a child playing
the actual child not Tobey Maguire plays
the adult version which yeah we really
what we so regretfully sees the narrator
as the adult version of the kid which
yet if you really want an enigmatic
narrator for your movie no one's better
than Tobey Maguire um like that should
just tell you how the tone is going to
be for the whole film and by that I mean
static and uninteresting so again not
mad at the child mad at a sound designer
the kid blows like three runs to make
kept them in the movie like he
mispronounces Christmas at one point and
they just didn't have him retake that
there's just like will LED Christmas
sounds close enough why not Christmas
Creek Sean Connery Julia
do you think though that that was love
or do you think that that was they were
trying to go with a cute kid sounds and
they kept that because of that it wasn't
it wasn't frequent enough that be a
thing also I don't flood I also don't
think that that's a trademark of
children that they pronounce Christmas
Christmas
there weren't like no puns which I feel
like would have fit in with this script
whereas I don't normally like to say we
have more puns in this film but this one
good may be benefited perfect good fun
yeah every aspect of this film could be
summarized with when given the
opportunity to do something better they
chose to not I yeah disappointing there
were so many things that had potential
to be funny like there was this whole
like nap gag where he would like fall
asleep Richard's really bought power nap
er well stress nap victory naps
those were the three that could have
been funny that could have been a funny
saying babies do that hilarious but they
weren't funny it didn't work it wasn't
it didn't hear smart but I like I saw
where they were trying to go there
didn't ya it's euro there if you're like
annoying friend who thinks that they've
got like a running gag that like Burton
and burns that gag into the ground like
a ghost in the shell' that's still funny
one of the funny ones was the wizard who
was it an alarm clock it was a Lord of
the Rings like tie in and she's a wizard
alarm clock right yeah and he was a is
7:45 wake up and then he would say
actualize rule or the review shall not
pass but they still didn't land right
well because like a lot of the jokes
were just references to Lord of the
Rings with no added anything to it they
just shoehorned in a Lord of the Rings
reference and the wizard alarm clock
like becomes animated like talks to him
and stuff like they have conversation
his imagination yeah which I enjoy I
like the line that they kind of skirt
with like what is real what is his
imagination so I like that he came alive
yes no no I like that part
I think the wizard is similar
where they I think they've burned the
wizard into the ground to like the
wizard I think is around too much and
for too long I wish that the wizard
would have been his little sidekick like
yeah I'm around with him at all times or
was less like towards the end I was like
I kind of wish this it was just a movie
about a boy and wizard alarm clock
pictures proven that you can make a good
movie for children and so I never I'm
never comfortable as the argument that
like well it's a kids movie so it can be
kind of lazy and bad because like
because you know because our children
are just the future it's not like we
need to care about their media uh but
when you have adult films that are lazy
and bad this is just one of the lazy and
bad kids oh sure and I but I hate this
awesome right I just don't want to like
give them a free pass because like well
if the kids movies it's okay no no free
pass I'm not coming for you it's not
like I'm not trying to attack camera no
no free pass but I think it's just one
of those ones that's like oh this wasn't
you know Star Wars this was a Pixar it's
one of those very like what was it
what's the Citizen Kane I never has
never seen a movie better than probably
you're right it shouldn't be it
shouldn't be a free back I just think I
don't know
stupid stupid fun movie that you
shouldn't see in theaters but like if
you want to read box it like no I just
cared too much about you know usually go
through such a thin and poor plot and
it's like there's so many different
easier ways that you can write such a
schlocky obvious movie and this one time
about where it's like when given the
opportunity to do better they don't
there are three emotional turns who of
them especially are completely unearned
like where the kit were the main
characters change fundamentally how they
feel about each other and they only
occur because they needed to further the
plot like there's nothing happens that
changes their mind and that's too
frustrating because it's just like it's
just poor filmmaking that's
super true and there was no moment when
I felt any tug of the heartstrings it's
not like amazing I I definitely didn't
hate it because we don't like hate
anything it was like it wasn't stellar
at all and and you're so you hit that
right on the head with the the emotional
turns it just wasn't there
I'm so happy to have someone this is no
one picks things out like that I'll just
be my aunt again I can watch these
travesties with because I don't want to
go to an 11:00 a.m. showing Abbas baby
by myself there's no amount of baby ones
that they can wave in front of my face
that will make me forget boss baby
forget movies forget movie forget movie
yes let's get you're not with me next
week no I am NOT I'm not here next week
where are you I'm in Texas I'm
performing in Texas we're at I am
performing stand-up at Haven con which
is a queer gaming convention in Austin
Texas
Cody is one of my absolute favorite
stand-up comedians in the city of
Chicago Burgess ever slow wise and very
smart
you are wise up said what I believe
that's what everyone loves in a comedian
my favorite state of comedian is owl
from Winnie the Pooh's
[Music]